what's going on guys this is rob and i
know i'm a little tardy to the party but
we're gonna watch the moon night trailer
so let's do this well if it's really a
trailer it's more of a first look but
we're gonna check it out because
god i'm so excited about moon night
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and
[Music]
the
dreams
in your head
it devours you
oh
okay so that little teaser trailer was
cool uh it was really just disney just
being like it exists right like it's
gonna be coming at some point on the
line i can't wait to see what an actual
full-on trailer looks like but from what
we did see it looked great like i love
the scene where he's just like pummeling
the guy just like beating the crap out
of the guy it looks like it's gonna be
pretty dark man like it looks like it's
really gonna be
like it's gonna be very similar to
batman which brings us into a very
interesting point and i had i have to
say this moon knife fans hate it when
you say this but it's actually an
accurate statement moon knight is
basically marvel's batman so one of the
funny things about this is it's like
when you break it down it's actually
kind of funny right so like moon knight
fans will be like he's nothing like
batman really what makes him different
from batman well the billionaire aspect
the billionaire personality is not named
bruce wayne it's named steve grant right
and the the the persona that moon knight
uses to go underground and infiltrate
the criminal underworld it's not matches
malone his name is jake lockley all
right he doesn't throw batarangs he
throws moon rings right it's totally
different they're not the same character
at
all totally separate that's basically
the argument that moon knight fans make
i'm sorry moon knight fans i gotta i
gotta poke at you guys a little bit you
know it's true i mean you know it's true
right i mean any moon knight fan is
honest with himself knows that it's true
but here's the cool thing about this
right in all honesty and for real over
true right all joking aside if i really
am kind of comparing the two i think
moon knight's a lot more interesting and
here's the reason why so the idea behind
moon knight as a character is that he's
basically a guy named mark spector at
least that's how he originally started
out he was a former marine and a cia
operative who basically ended up
becoming a mercenary eventually he
worked alongside an archaeologist and a
guy named bushman who was also a
mercenary and then during this great big
huge archaeological dig bushmen
basically betrayed everybody killed the
archaeologist and left mark spector for
dead eventually mark spector is taken
before this statue of an egyptian god
named konchu and then suddenly just
wakes up he basically is totally healed
and all that kind of cool stuff right
now all this stuff is covered in the
original werewolf by night number 32
which is when he originally first
appeared the bigger issue here is you
never really understood the nature of
konshu he didn't know if he was real or
if he was just kind of some aspect of
mark spector's consciousness whatever
the case was but he ended up basically
stating this idea that he was supposed
to effectively be a superhero on earth
avenging the wicked in the name of
konshu and just kind of going forward
and doing doing his own thing eventually
you find out konshu is actually real
right that he is actually a god that
exists out there now over the years mark
spector has had some really really cool
situations and cool stories but the way
this worked was that in order to
effectively
do his job right to basically be a
superhero out there that mark specter
fashioned the identity of moon knight
now that's the first thing to keep in
mind the second thing is he needed
identities that would let him infiltrate
different aspects of society an identity
that would let him infiltrate the
criminal underworld or the very least
keep his ear to the ground and
understand the kind of rumblings that
are going on out there and the second
one was to actually infiltrate white
collar crime to basically be a guy that
could get in with the super rich and
find out what nefarious things they're
doing so we can ultimately stop them the
ear to the ground the the kind of
infiltrating the criminal underworld
personality or at least identity that
was jake lockley he was a cab driver the
super rich billionaire guy that's steve
grant right now here's the funny thing
about this over the years in marvel
comics if you look at the stories right
the old doug mink stories and all that
kind of stuff marvel kind of teased this
idea that mark specter was sort of
losing himself to a degree and all these
different stories actually came to a
head in the most recent run by jeff
lemire which was a phenomenal one not
really the most recent there's actually
an ongoing one right now but the run
before that by jeff lemire was a really
really really good run in effect what
had happened here is that mark spector
had transitioned between his identities
so often that he actually began to
forget who he was that he basically
started developing disassociative
identity disorder now that was the
initial stepping stone right this idea
that he had he was so ingrained in these
personalities that you didn't know where
mark specter ended and steve grant began
and you didn't know if it was actually
steve grant and he was pretending to be
mark spector somewhere along the line
that's where all the stories really
began to go crazy right they really
began to mesh kind of come together so
he didn't really know who he was now in
more recent years one of the things that
you've also learned is that the
identities of like jake lockley and
those guys that those are actually a
result of the disassociative identity
disorder that marx spectre struggles
with in effect there are multiple
personalities that manifested through
his childhood they've always been there
they just didn't come out until recently
and so the cool thing about jeff
lemire's ron is it was actually all
these personalities meeting each other
for the first time and it was great
right like all the personalities met and
then basically coalesced to figure out
who's who and like who mark specter
actually is right it was a phenomenal
story i won't ruin any more than that
but i would highly suggest you guys
check it out i feel like we started it
over comics explained and then never
finished it the important thing about
this is that for the tv show i don't
know how far reaching this is going to
be one of the things to know is that in
the comics at least in the early days
and it's one of those things that's kind
of waxed and waned with mark spector's
character over the years is that
whenever there was a full moon he was
basically empowered by consho right so
like his strength speed durability all
that kind of stuff would be enhanced
he'd be a far more capable and powerful
fighter now we're also talking within
reason right it's not like there'd be a
full moon and moon knight would be like
on par with the incredible hulk that's
not really what happened although there
was one point where he fought the great
hulk in vegas that was cool
that was an amazing story i loved that
story
that was so cool when he fought joe
fixing hulk that was awesome but outside
of that uh there really isn't too much
to go on with moon knight it's really
more of the circumstances in his stories
that make him wildly interesting now
with the show itself this could be a
pretty simple and easy to understand
show or it could feel like legion from
fx if i'm being honest with you guys
i'm kind of hoping it feels like legion
because what made legion so cool was the
fact that you didn't know what was going
on you didn't know if he was like
hallucinating
if all of it was actually happening if
it was all inside of his head if he
really was just surrounded by people
that all had just crazy extraordinary
powers and he was in an actual tangible
location none of these things were made
readily available and so it was it was
really really confusing but also
exciting at the outset because it was
like a giant mystery that you wanted to
solve and that i imagine is something
they're going to roll with when it comes
to this show that over time you're going
to see the initial introduction of mark
spector as the mercenary and then the
events are going to unfold which will
likely involve bushman and then he'll
basically be betrayed he'll meet the
egyptian god konshu and he'll go forward
as moon knight crafting that identity
for himself then he's going to create
the identity of jake lockley then he's
going to create the identity of steve
grant and he's going to kind of
infiltrate society in those different
and varying roles but as the show
progresses he's not going to know who he
is the other thing about this though is
if you look at it almost looks like he
kind of snaps right he kind of loses his
mind in the sense that like he just
wakes up with like all these bodies
around him so it could be where it's
very very similar to the movie split
right where he really does have multiple
personality disorder and that one of the
one of the alters as they call it takes
over and then during that time mark
spector blacks out he doesn't know what
happens which there's actually
precedence for this that was the basis
behind the old incredible hulk stories
right like in the old incredible hulk
stories whenever the incredible hulk
persona came out bruce banner would
never know what the incredible hulk did
he had basically blacked out he was just
in this giant kind of darkness would
have no idea what's going on and then
suddenly the incredible hulk persona
would revert and bruce banner would come
back out and then he'd have to deal with
whatever the aftermath was of what the
incredible hulk did that was how much
kind of explained why banner was always
on the run right because incredible hulk
was just a big lumbering rampaging beast
but i imagine you could see that
happening with moon knight right that he
has multiple personality disorder one of
the altars takes over and that mark
specter just kind of has to deal with
the aftermath of this right trying to
figure out what's going on why all this
is happening because if he is just in
bed one day right like he's like okay
i'm just having to lay down and go to
bed and then he wakes up in somebody
else's house bodies all around him he's
not gonna know what's going on so the
show may very well be kind of exist in
two parts right that one part is mark
spector trying to understand what in the
hell is going on around him
and the other part is actually us kind
of figuring out what's going on around
him and watching as essentially oscar
isaac tries to understand what's
happening himself right i don't know if
that makes any sense very similar to
like christopher nolan's memento that
makes any sense but regardless i'm
excited for the show it looks like it's
going to be really really really cool uh
regardless man like it's it's uh i'm
glad to see moon knights finally getting
some attention the one thing i'm hoping
for the most is that the show is
actually going gonna be really really
dark and really really gritty uh not too
much so but enough that you can walk
away and be like okay so like moon
knight's definitely somebody to like
never trifle with right because if
marvel and disney are really gonna go in
the direction of the midnight sun so
like blade ghost rider morbius all that
kind of stuff you're gonna need a dark
moon night right like a brutal and dark
moon you're gonna need that guy because
if they're gonna do what i think they're
gonna do with with midnight suns
it'll be brutal and it'll be dark
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace